The world suddenly doesn't
care about the war in Ukraine.
I actually experienced this.
We recently published a video
about drone warfare
in the war in Ukraine,
and it was one of the more
ambitious videos I've ever made,
and yet it like flopped.
And I don't have videos flop
very often, this is weird.
And I was scratching my head
until I started to realize
that the world
is losing interest in this war.
Like, this was like
the focus of the entire world for years.
Western people and governments
have been pouring money
and attention
and support on Ukraine
since Russia invaded.
But now
governments are debating whether or not
they should give any money
or weapons to Ukraine anymore.
People have turned their attention
to other things.
The war in Israel is pulling people's
attention away.
Global conflict
really relies on global attention.
A conflict like the war in Ukraine
could be won or lost based on
how much we pay attention to it,
how much we pressure our government
to continue to support it.
That support seems to be waning
and the people of Ukraine
and their leaders are pretty nervous.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.